facebook c'est un peu big brother si
vous allez sur internet facebook veulent
savoir et en profiter pour vous montrer
encore et encore de la pub c'est seul
contrat facebook est gratuit mais en
échange il vous suit partout même à
l'extérieur de facebook ce qui lui
permet de savoir tout tout tout sur vous
qui vous êtes et ce que vous faites mais
à un moment donné ça vaut faire vous
pouvez freiner les ardeurs de facebook
en désactivant quatre paramètres dans
votre profil activités futures en dehors
de facebook données de votre activité
partagée par nos partenaires publicité
montré hors de facebook et historique de
localisation taper ces mots clés sur
internet pour savoir comment faire bien
sûr ce que vous faites dans facebook
reste étroitement surveillés donc vos
j'aime vos commentaires vos partages et
publications pour que ce ne soit plus le
cas il faudrait quitter facebook
avant d'en arriver là commencez par
empêcher facebook de voir ce que vous
faites à l'extérieur
passés le mot
[Musique]